let's talk about multiplying by ten a
hundred and a thousand
there's some cool number patterns that
happen with each of these so let's start
here with something like four times ten
one that maybe we're comfortable with or
already know
four times ten
would be the same
as saying four
tens
four
and four tens
one way we could represent that is a ten
plus a second ten it's a third ten plus
a fourth ten
or four
tens
and now let's count that
ten plus ten is twenty plus ten is
thirty plus ten is 40.
so our solution
is 40 or a 4
with a zero
and this is the pattern that we've seen
before
when we multiply 4 times 10 we keep our
whole number of 4
and we add a 0 to the end
for the times 10.
so another example of that might be
something like 8 times 10
well 8 times 10 is the same as 8 tens
and this time let's just count them if
we count 8 10s it'll be 10 20 30 40 50
60 70 80.
so when i counted 8 tens
the solution was 80 or an 8
with a 0 on the end
so times 10 when we multiply a whole
number times 10
the pattern
is that we end up adding a zero to the
end of our whole number
so let's take now what we already know
about tens and let's apply it to
hundreds
something like let's say two
times one hundred
there's a couple ways we can think about
this one way is to say that this is the
same as two
hundreds
two hundreds
which is one hundred plus another
hundred there is quite literally two
hundreds
which is a total
of two
hundred or two
with two zeros on the end now we have
two zeros on the end
or another way to think about this is
two two times one hundred instead of
saying times a hundred
we could say times 10
times 10
because 10 times 10 is the same as 100
and 2 times 10 we know is a 2 with a 0
on the end
which is 20
and 20 times 10 then will be 20
with a 0 on the end
because we multiplied by 10 twice we
added two zeros
and multiplying by a hundred is just
that it's exactly that it's multiplying
by ten twice
so if times ten adds one zero
then times a hundred or times ten twice
adds
two zeros to our answer
and we can go even further and think
about thousands let's try something like
nine
times one thousand
well we could think of this as nine
thousands and if we have nine thousands
then we have one thousand two thousand
three thousand four thousand five
thousand that was five
six thousand seven thousand eight
thousand nine thousand so when i counted
a thousand nine times
our solution was nine thousand
or looking at the numbers a nine our
original whole number
with three
zeros after it so nine times a thousand
is nine thousand or nine with three
zeros
and we can go back to what we did before
thinking about this in terms of tens
we've worked out
why multiplying by ten adds a zero
so let's think about one thousand in
terms of tens
one thousand
is equal to ten
times ten
ten times ten
is a hundred
and a hundred tens
is a thousand
so instead of one thousand we can write
ten times ten times ten these are
equivalent
and so when we multiply a number times
10 we add a zero
but here we're multiplying by three tens
so we add
three zeros
so let's look at that all as one pattern
let's say something let's take seven
the number seven
and let's multiply it by ten
by a hundred
and by a thousand
and see what happens
seven times ten
is going to be seven with one zero
because we have one ten
seven times a hundred will be seven with
two zeros because again one hundred is
the same as ten times ten
so this is seven times ten twice so we
have two zeros
and seven times a thousand will be seven
thousand or seven with three zeros
because a thousand
is equal to ten
times ten
or
three tens so we add one two three zeros
and so we can see the pattern here when
we multiply by 10 which has one zero
we add one zero to the end of our whole
number
when we multiply a whole number times a
hundred which has two zeros we add two
zeros for hundreds
and for thousands when we multiply by
one thousand we'll add three zeros to
the end of a whole number